as temperatures start to heat up many
are heading out to lake mead to cool off
but the national recreation area is now
easing or asking voters to prepare for
lower water levels
reporter kate houston went out to a
popular launch ramp to see what the
national park service is doing to help
here at hemingway harbor low water
levels are already impacting the boat
launch area
lake mead says that this is one of
several popular access points that will
be impacted
it was a busy morning at lake mead as
dozens of boaters launched into the
water where's my son's
19th birthday so we didn't want the low
water levels to
stop us from coming out having a good
time frederick wilford senior noticed
the receding water line right away
if you look around you can see where it
was here with the rim and a lot of
things that are exposed now that wasn't
exposed
several years ago lake mead national
recreation area is expecting levels to
go down to 1068 feet by the end of
summer
which is the lowest it's been since the
reservoir was filled in the 1930s
there's rocks that was pretty much say
20 30 feet down below
that's actually up higher so you
definitely can destroy your boat
if you don't stay out in the middle to
help keep these access points open
maintenance teams are installing
repurposed pipe mats to temporarily
extend the concrete
lake mead is asking boaters to prepare
for delays and some temporary closures
be flexible if you find that your
favorite launch ramp location is going
to be delayed you might want to look at
launching at a different location at
that point in time
greg hobarger with lake mead says 5
million dollars is being committed to
extend the concrete ramps this year
that cost will rise significantly to 12
million dollars in 2022
and 100 million dollars in 2023 he says
they're working on ways to fund the
projects
kate houston 8 news now